En este video hablaremos sobre algunas de las
dificultades que alguien podría enfrentar al
intentar resolver una ecuación cuadrática como
esta. ¿Por qué es una ecuación cuadrática? Bueno,
es cuadrática porque tiene este término de segundo
grado justo aquí, y es una ecuación porque hay
algo en ambos lados de un signo =. Entonces,
una estrategia que la gente podría intentar es,
ya que tenemos algo al cuadrado, ¿por qué no
tratar de sacar la raíz cuadrada de ambos lados?
Y si hiciéramos eso obtendríamos la √ x² + 4 x +
3 = √ -1. Inmediatamente vemos algunos problemas,
incluso si esto no fuera negativo aquí -ese es
el problema más obvio-, pero aunque esto fuera
un valor positivo, ¿cómo simplificaríamos o cómo
aislaríamos esta x? Hemos llegado bastante rápido
a un callejón sin salida: tomar la raíz cuadrada
de ambos lados de una cuadrática sin ton ni son
no será muy útil, así que pondré una gran X por
aquí. Otra estrategia que a veces las personas
tratan de hacer es aislar primero la x². Para
que puedas imaginarlo, permíteme reescribirlo:
x² + 4 x + 3 = -1. Podrían decir "Aislemos
esa x² restando 4x en ambos lados y restando
3 en ambos lados", y luego ¿qué pasa? En el lado
izquierdo, de hecho, queda sola la x² y en el
lado derecho obtienes -4 x - 4. Y ahora podrían
decir "Si tomo la raíz cuadrada de ambos lados,
podría obtener...", ahora voy a escribirlo: √ x²
es igual a, y podría intentar sacar el positivo
y el negativo en un lado para considerar
las raíces negativas: 4x negativo - 4,
y podría obtener algo como esto, obtendría:
x = ± √ -4x -4, pero esto aún no sirve todavía,
no sabemos qué es x y realmente no está claro
qué hacer con esto algebraicamente; entonces,
este es otro callejón sin salida. Ahora, hay
algunos casos en los que esta estrategia podría
haber funcionado, de hecho hubiera funcionado
si no tuviera este término primer grado,
si no tuviera este término x, por así decirlo;
entonces esta estrategia habría funcionado
suponiendo que hay algunas soluciones, pero si
tenemos un término x como este y no se cancela
de alguna manera -ya sabes, si hubiera otro 4x en
el otro lado, entonces podrías restar 4x de ambos
lados y se cancelarían-, pero si no puedes hacer
que desaparezcan estas cosas esta estrategia que
acabo de describir no será productiva. Otra
estrategia que a veces usan las personas,
especialmente cuando ven algo como esto -permíteme
volver a escribirlo: x² + 4 x + 3 = 1 negativo-,
inmediatamente intentan factorizarlo, dicen
"Oye, espera, creo que podría factorizar esto:
puedo pensar en dos números cuya suma es 4 y cuyo
producto es 3, quizá 3 y 1", y entonces factorizan
inmediatamente esta expresión del lado izquierdo y
les queda (x + 3 ) (x + 1) y luego será igual a 1
negativo, y luego, o están a punto de cometer
un error, ya que esto en realidad es válido
algebraicamente, pero o se equivocan o sea dan
cuenta de que están en un callejón sin salida,
porque sólo decir que algo multiplicado por algo
es igual a 1 negativo no ayuda mucho, debido a que
aún no está claro cómo resolverían para x. Otra
cosa que tratan de hacer es decir "Por lo tanto,
x = 3 negativo o x = 1 negativo porque 3 negativo
hará que este primer término sea igual a 0 o 1
negativo hará que el segundo término sea 0"; pero
recuerda que esto sólo es cierto si multiplicas
dos cosas y su producto es cero. Entonces las
soluciones serían cualquier cosa que hicieran que
alguno de estos términos fuera igual a 0. Pero eso
no es lo que estamos tratando aquí; aquí nos dicen
que el producto es igual a 1 negativo, por lo que
para factorizar así y avanzar en la mayoría de los
casos querrás tener un 0 aquí en el lado derecho.
Y eso también es cierto si estamos tratando de
aplicar la fórmula cuadrática. Mucha gente diría
"Está bien, veo una ecuación cuadrática aquí,
permíteme aplicar la fórmula cuadrática: dicen
que si tengo algo de la forma ax² + bx + c = 0,
por la fórmula cuadrática las raíces van a
ser x = -b ± √ b² - 4ac, todo eso sobre 2a",
y entonces dirán de inmediato "Muy bien, aquí hay
un coeficiente implícito: a es 1, b es 4, c es 3",
y dirán que x = -4 ± √ b² que es 16 - 4 • 1 • 3
y todo esto entre 2 por 1. Pero hay un problema:
la fórmula cuadrática se aplica cuando el lado
izquierdo es igual a 0, eso no es lo que tenemos
aquí, entonces estamos cayendo en el mismo error,
por lo que nada de lo que acabo de escribir es una
buena idea. Entonces, la forma de abordar esto,
si deseamos tener un 0 aquí, es sumar 1 en el
lado derecho y, para mantener la igualdad, debemos
agregar 1 en el lado izquierdo, y entonces vamos
a obtener x² + 4 x + 4 = 0. Y ahora sí podemos
usar la fórmula cuadrática o podríamos factorizar,
podemos reconocer que 2 + 2 = 4, 2 • 2 = 4,
entonces podríamos decir que (x + 2) (x + 2) = 0.
En este caso, x podría ser igual a 2 negativo
o x podría ser igual a 2 negativo, así que ésta
tiene sólo una solución: x = 2 negativo. Pero la
clave es reconocer que necesitamos el 0 en el lado
derecho si queremos usar una fórmula cuadrática
o factorizar y usar la propiedad del producto 0.